let's face it blacks your lives here  stink you live in terrible neighborhoods  you have no jobs you're in prison and  you're in constant fear of dinosaur  attack but that all changes when I  president you might love me I'm gonna  give you everything you are starting a  day one every black person gets a free  eight ball Jackie hi I'm gonna have  positions in my cabinet for Bell Biv and  even divine plus I'll make Denzel  Washington head of the FAA because he  did such a terrific job flying that  plane upside down when I am president  every Prince will be fresh for Congress  to make dominoes and an Olympic sport  I'll add a special fifth time zone for  colored people time I'll invest every  resource I have to get that horrible  thing of a Mike Tyson offense and listen  to this I'll make sure all black people  has their very own bathrooms and  waterfowl  how about that come on blacks let's make  America great again  you guys love their glitter - okay  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you